this is synched a kawaii community
matters here hi you've joined it you
know lickable science I'm your host
Ethan Allen here on think tech Hawaii
thanks for joining us today and what is
more lickable than food I love food
right and today joining you by Skype is
dr. Joseph - Frank hi Joe bye Ethan
how's it going it's always a pleasure to
be back with you and likeable science
right great to have you on board again
here so Joe - Frank is a plant scientist
tropical plant and soil science group at
uhm on OA
it's got a doctorate from Michigan State
a bit ago and he works on all kinds of
things related to weed control and but
not in the traditional way lot of people
now think of it as we control with
chemicals and pesticides Joe's really
very interested in in sort of
appropriate non pesticide non chemical
through low tech ways that we can we can
control weeds and keep the soil intact
we don't have to tilt it up and and all
that kind of stuff that takes energy
time so once you tell us a little bit
about sort of go back in the history of
agriculture as it were Joe to give us a
little context great Ethan well what
we're going to talk about today is
no-till farming for organic farmers as
well as home gardeners no-till farming
came into prominence in the American
agriculture sometime around 1973
about the time when we had the bowl was
called the Arab oil embargo where
farmers needed to reduce their energy
consumption with gasoline right so in
one of the ways they did that was by
trying to reduce the plowing of the
fields in preparation for seeding
yes that's what you mean by no-till
right yes not plowing oh so we don't
want to plow so generally what you would
do is you would have like a crop of
winter wheat for example and instead of
plowing down the remaining stubble of
the wheat in the spring of the year they
would spray it to kill whatever her
weeds were there and then they would use
specialized planners the plant seeds
directly into that stubble so you would
have a nice mulch to retain moisture
around soil erosion and of course you
say baby four or five trips across the
field by not plowing oh I was interested
at in the early 70s at Michigan State
and then all these years I've been
trying to figure out a way we could
adapt that system for organic farm right
because for again a farmers of course
they don't want to spray it and spray
the chemicals on the previous cover of
crop and you know they can't do that in
call it organic anymore so what would
your session Brix so organic farmers of
course they can't spray herbicides to
kill off weeds and the only way they can
terminate a cover crop number crop is
going to be a plant that you're not
going to eat you're not going to consume
it's there to enrich the soil increase
aeration and also serve as a break for
certain pests so once you have this
vigorous cover crop on the soil surface
organic farmers were restricted to using
the plow or disc to invert the soil bury
that organic matter and then have a
clean surface in which to plant in of
course that takes a lot of energy has a
pretty big carbon footprint with the
tractors moving and so forth so what we
were wanting to do is to develop a
system where busying something other
than the plow and the tractor to
terminate the cover crop or using light
exclusion and light exclusion through
the use of these durable woven plastic
fabrics is what we've been experimenting
with right because plan says everyone
knows need light to grow right and if
you really cover your plant over well
and keep it dark the green plants don't
get the light
they don't manufacture their own food
they up and die right so it's there's
nothing new there plants need light they
don't get light they die so let me just
briefly through what we're talking about
in terms of a technique for commercial
farmers as well as home gardeners I
think it really shines for homeowners
who may not be too crazy about taking a
shovel to the ground and flipping it
over so yeah we rose to
is that you need to establish a cover
crop for whatever reason like I said
organic matter add nitrogen through
legumes and allow that thing to grow
vigorously to the point where you want
to plant your cash crop at that point
what conventional organic farmers are
doing is doing what's called creeping or
rolling right that means there we go
alright we got we got the pictures up
now alright so this is the first picture
here ok so the first picture is actually
our student the gardens in the weed
science class this fall but uhm Noah and
what you're looking at is a five species
cover crop meaning that there's five
different see that were playing it give
you this a diverse nice green luscious
crop in in the composition there that
you're looking at is Calpis borage
radish black mustard outs and buckwheat
so we have a diverse group of cover
crops that we we can address any sort of
pests that may be adapt it's one of them
we know will have something there
that'll that'll grow well and the alpi
of course is a legume that's gonna pull
nitrogen from the air and add it to the
soil excellent that would be the first
picture right so next here we go there's
somebody rolling okay so the next
picture you see a student they're using
a roller to crush down the cover crop a
farmers would be using a tractor based
roller and maybe not a smooth over one
with crimpers you know these rays that
is that and break the stem so what what
organic farmers try to do is terminate
the cover crop by you know crushing the
stems and then they plant their crop in
there the only problem is is that may
not completely fill the cover crop there
may be weeds underneath that emerge once
you master you do the rolling right next
picture would be illustrating the weed
mats or the thurible polypropylene
fabrics that are available at most
stores that sell commercial supplies to
nurseryman and so forth right now wait
these down on their edges with some sort
of little sandbags or water tube or
something so what we're using
for securing that plastic to the ground
is what everybody who's familiar with
ten fumigation in Hawaii whenever they
fumigate your house they usually use
water filled hoses to secure the plastic
to the ground so it doesn't come off so
that's what we're using to get these
used fire hoses fill them with water or
we even have some hoses filled with say
in the shorter lengths and that way we
can like we can cover the cover the
ground and then secure the fabric in
windy areas with water filled hoses so
it's a convenient way to hold it in
place without poking holes and without
having a bunch of rocks and stones to
lug around and then take off what we
want to remove it ya know it's beautiful
that it makes a nice solid light tight
cover and when you remove it then it's
the next photo I think we'll show now
when you remove it what you're looking
at there is a one week of coverage so
what we do is we rolled that cover crop
we covered it for one week and you might
not think that one week of coverage is
enough to disable that rubber crop but
it is because it's high dark and so now
that the cover crop is killed you
haven't we haven't done any additional
work we haven't used any chemicals now
we're ready to plant but I believe in
them in the next image we'll see that
the corn transplants have been playing
it if that's up and then you can see
that the corn is growing normally so I
say well what's what's remarkable about
all this well what's remarkable that
number one we haven't plowed the ground
that soil has been laying unplowed for
well over a year and so it's relatively
firm but what we do is we poke a hole in
the ground we put in corn transplants
because we want to give the corn a big
jump on any weeds that might grow and we
just poke a hole on the ground sticking
the corn transplants cover it back up
keep irrigating and the nutrients are
released from that dead and dying cover
crop and voila we have no-till farming
for organic farmers yeah beautiful
beautiful and in that one week of course
right not only does the existing plants
that were there they're all starting to
die and decay but then any weed seeds or
anything probably start to sprout but
without
light they're not gonna do anything
right that's correct so generally
whenever you play in a cover crop like
that not only are you getting the cover
crop you're gonna get certain weeds that
grow and they may be suppressed by the
vigorous cover crop but once that canopy
is removed those weeds will just sprout
up that's the advantage of combining
rolling and crimping with covering that
we kill the cover crop and we kill
whatever weeds may be in the understory
of the cover crop exactly yeah that's
beautiful nice wonderful how you put
these sort of seemingly simple little
bits and pieces you know the idea of a
roller to crush the cover crop down idea
of a like tight cover over the the
ground
roughly simple concept nothing really
high-tech nothing that had to be mixed
up in a chemical lab nothing that didn't
involve some fancy machine that's right
right so it's all relatively
straightforward and you say well yeah I
guess you just cover it up and then
everything dies and you pull it off and
then your plant makes a lot of sense
challenges is how large a scale can we
do that you can imagine if you have a
you know plastic that's you know 300
feet long and 12 feet wide that could be
pretty challenging laying it out in the
field and then securing it so the
question is not every crop would be
adapted to this I see that the majority
of crops that would be at that would be
things like mallow greens or microgreens
where you can more or less seated in a
complete block and then harvest you know
things aren't in rows or just growing as
a complete flock and in that way these
organic farmers who are getting a
premium for their products will have
incentive to try to do this of course
there's expense to the plastic but as
opposed to plowing and tractors and if
it rains you take it in the field and it
gives the I think farmers a lot more
flexibility in timing when they pull off
that fabric they might want to wait
until they may have a bunch of these
fabrics out there they pull one off
plant but that gets
started well the next one open plant and
they don't have to worry about weeds
growing while they're timing the plane
things of their crop so I just think it
adds a lot of flexibility for commercial
farmers and for the homeowner it's great
too because you may have a piece of
ground that's a weedy mess and you go
yeah I like to start gardening dr. D how
do I do it I say well but get a sheet of
plastic which you can get it various
hardware stores now this is a plastic
that's woven it's not a film so it
allows the irrigation water to go
through it so we just knock down the
weeds cover them
eeep moisten the soil over the top with
irrigation and then when you're ready to
plant pull it off put a hole in the
ground and plan some transplants and see
what you get of course you got to
fertilize but you're not plowing the
ground so you're not going to get a
whole bunch of weeds and if you mulch if
you add mulch in addition to your
transplants you might be able to get
away with a prop without any weeding
whatsoever and then you're done with the
field
all right backed up and when you're
ready to Braille again pull it pull it
off and plant again yeah it's it seems
like it's got a lot going for it and
makes a lot of sense it would seem like
it's economical to a good extent the
fabric I assumed to be used at least
several times certainly right oh yes the
fabric is very durable and I would
expect that you know a farmer would get
I don't know maybe five years of use
from a piece of fabric and then I think
they would get you know if they if they
worked it out where they they had their
crops on a regular basis I think they
could actually make money on it and the
reason why I throw this out were farmers
to think about is because the farmers
are gonna innovate on how are they going
to how are they going to use it how they
going to time their plantings and or you
know picking it up and rolling it when
it's a big sheet of plastic that's gonna
take a couple people so that's where you
need a but if you know more than more
than one person pulling it off rolling
it up and getting it ready for the next
usage so there's some innovation that
the farmers will need to come up with
really make this an efficient practice
sure like almost any technology you need
to
a bit to it you need to think of some
new ways to sort of support it and apply
it but it's it you've got you've given
people really a really nice set of tools
to use a really interesting approach
that should be really applicable and as
you say for sort of moderate scale
organic farms for things like the mixed
greens and salad mix kind of stuff that
should be really sort of perfect thing
ya know farmer can get two or three
people out there they could they could
do a number of these patches at once
they can wait until they see the there's
rains on their way so it won't have to
irrigate as much too hot
timing whole issue is really great a lot
of advantages just I can see yeah and
one of the big advantages is you know in
Hawaii you know we always think that
it's always a great growing season year
round but we do have a rainy cycles and
one of the big problems is that for
organic farmers is we control you ask
any organic farmer one of the biggest
challenges for production is we control
so let's say you get into a rainy spell
November December it's raining every
other day you can't go out in the field
and control those weeds with mowing and
plowing because it's too wet you're just
stuck there watching the weeds grow and
watching them put out seeds but the
ground is covered with this fabric
there's no worries you know the the
weeds are going to grow as a matter of
fact adding moisture once the fabric is
there is causing weeds that are in the
soil to germinate thinking that they're
going to reach the surface but they here
they're underneath of plastic so what
you're actually doing is purging right
beet seeds from the production cycle but
it's the actual way to store the soil
get a bunch of weeds to germinate and
and the farmer it could be the wettest
day of the year when he wants to peel
all of that plastic plant you know like
I said for moderate sized farmers or for
you know large own gardeners I think
it's a real a real you know simple
innovation makes sense to the average
person to go yeah and why didn't
somebody think of that before
so when I said the same thing I go well
I wonder if anybody's gonna think that
this is a realistic thing and then I
started doing my laboratories with the
students and they just seemed to accept
it as you okay that that's okay that's
fine now that looks good right and
we're gonna we're gonna dig into this in
more depth here when we come back but
right now we have to take a quick break
here we'll be right back Jodi Frank is
with me here I'm your host Ethan Helen
here on likable science and we'll be
back in a minute
[Music]
so any
so it Aloha my name is Marx klav I am
the host of Fink tech Hawaii's law
across the sea law across the sea comes
on every other Monday at 11:00 a.m.
please join us
I like to bring in guests that talk
about all types of things that come
across the sea to Hawaii not just law
love people ideas history please join us
for law across the sea Allah and you're
back here on likable science I'm your
host Ethan Allen here on the attack
Hawaii with me today via Skype is dr.
Joseph de Frank
welcome again Joe Nathan good to be back
again yes indeed and we're talking about
some innovations that Joe has developed
a really a very interesting sort of
low-tech but but very effective ways to
help gardeners small-scale farmers avoid
the need to till the soil to turn on
their soil to have the heavy equipment
to run their tractors his approach by
essentially crushing a cover crop and
then covering it for as little as a week
really opens up some some great
opportunities and one of the nice things
I was thinking a little bit over the
break via it was you can leave that
cover than in place right sort of as
long as you want you say a week but it
doesn't hurt if it stays on for two
weeks three weeks or whatever right
right we've had it on as long as eight
nine months over the summer just waiting
for the class to start we pull it off
and we're ready to go so a great way to
store the soil eventually store that
soil in a in a ready condition for
planting with little to no effort it's
just there ready to go yeah it's not
it's not your roading you're not getting
new weed growth it's not blowing away
it's not packing down it's it's just as
you say it's sort of sitting there
waiting yeah yeah oh it's it's a good
way to store store the soil in the go
mode for planting yeah so I mean if you
look in that soil just just this is
purely my curiosity look in that soil
you'll find the same kinds of
invertebrate populations earthworms and
various little bugs all sort of sitting
there doing their little business right
right and what we found is that you know
if we leave that cover on for you know
if we cover but if we put the plastic
over the top of weeds or or or other
cover crops what happens is that we have
a real explosion of soil insects that
consume that organic matter because
they're not being preyed on by birds so
you have an accelerated breakdown of the
organic matter in a mineralization of
those nutrients back to the soil so all
around it's a it's a pretty interesting
approach and it also gives us an opening
for a pest management there's a thing
called nematodes in the soil nematodes
are microscopic worms and will penetrate
the roots and ruin them and for organic
farmers it's very difficult to get rid
of those microscopic worms but we've
developed a way to combine a cover crop
with the plastic to accelerate the
removal of these microscopic pests and
the way that works is a little
counterintuitive you know you think that
well if I got this soil borne worm
that's eating my roots
I gotta plant things that that aren't
susceptible to it right but the
counterintuitive idea is to know we're
gonna plan something that's super
sensitive because these nematodes
respond to root exudates of the septum
aplan and just like a seed those
nematodes germinate from eggs so once
they perceive the roots growing a
Germany and they try to attach to the
plant but if we know the lifecycle of
those nematodes we can then roll that
fabric before they start to reproduce
cover it up with plastic the plants dies
the nematode dies now we have a non
chemical way to get rid of this very
persistent and challenging soil pest
nematodes and use the same technique
only with a slight little variation
where be playing a susceptible crop
makes the nematodes come to life they
try to attach to the roots and before
they can reproduce we kill off the plant
with this covering and nematodes die we
pull it off and then we play
susceptible crops oh it it's also giving
us a new approach to pest management I
don't think we've we've thought about it
in that way I like that that's it sort
of a little a little a fake-out a little
faint as it were you you draw them out
by print planting something they really
like when they all sort of go for that
then you zap them basically you can
cover the cover over and they can't they
don't get a second chance basically
right no I didn't think that up years
ago we had a scientist from North
Carolina State Don Schmidt and he was a
guy he was always testing chemicals for
nematode control and soybeans he goes
you know Joe the best year that I had
was when we had an early spring in North
Carolina I mid the soybeans I put out
all my treatments but then we had a
early frost and all the soybeans died
when we re-established the experiments
and we threw the soybeans again we
couldn't tell untreated fields from
treated fields because of just what I
said the nematodes all came into the
soybeans the frost killed him he died
and so it's the same concept sort of
like a a bait and switch your roots and
then you switch him by turning off the
lights that's beautiful that's beautiful
yeah and it looks to me like this has a
lot of interesting options to go new
places right I mean this you're using
right now one kind of fabric but you
could conceivably think about that
fabric in different ways right right now
I was thinking like how can we make this
better you know the fabric is kind of
heavy when you get large sheets of it
you know it gets to be kind of
cumbersome to pick it up and put it away
and and one of the things that happens
when we use the fabric of course we can
kill a living plant but sometimes
there's weed seeds that need light to
germinate and grow so what happens then
is that we gotta we gotta stimulate
those weed seeds to grow over it kill
them off and then uncover it now with
all the budding engineers and nanotech
scientists out there it occurred to me
that you know we we probably have the
technology somewhere in our industrial
base to do what I call
nano blankets or nano fabric so what
would that be that would be like a super
light fabric that you know with a
certain electrical potential it's
translucent and let's light into the
soil so that would I would allow the
weed seeds to grow underneath of the
blanket and now we add another little
electrical potential and they reorient
the molecules and then it turns it black
then the weeds die so this way we could
start to purge beet seeds that are light
sensitive grow without pulling the
fabric on and off and then once the
fabric is all the weeds are dead boom we
pull it off and move it to another field
so I think that there's probably you
know engineers out there that maybe have
is ready to go maybe it's ready for off
you know they're using it as a as a
blanket for a space shuttle the block
light or to turn it on and off but I
don't think I've never heard of an
agricultural use for such a thing but
I'm sure there might be some compliances
out there that maybe they can let us
know if they got something like that and
we can work together on yeah I sounds
great I mean it actually reminds me a
bit of the another one of my sort of
favorite technological advances which is
the a thing called Mattie drops which
was a ceramic chemist
Jim Smith from the University of
Virginia had been working for years on
pushing water through porous ceramics to
help filter it and clean it up and
adding silver into that helped kill off
the the microbes as it went through and
finally realized that he didn't actually
need to push the water through it he
essentially put sawdust in with the clay
and the silver nitrate baked it in a
kiln and got a very porous ceramic so
water flowed by itself in through there
and literally pulled off the silver and
distributed this over around the water
killing off all the microbes sort of
again it's nice little aloe to a
low-tech twist on a hi-tech idea and I
like what you're thinking about there I
think it has a lot of that potential
great yeah so that's that's kind of what
I wanted to share with everybody today
and like I said everybody thinks that we
need to plow through in a soft soil for
roots to grow but really I like to say
let the worms do
flowey you know we had enough organic
matter and the plant roots when they
died make channels and the worms come up
and and eat the organic matter so I say
let them let the worms do the plough and
we'll do the planting and the eat yeah
yeah people don't appreciate how how
much work worms do what is it they say
in the over the course of a year the
worms in an acre of ground will turn
over something like a ton of soil or
something some some incredible figure I
heard I don't know I'm sure it's
incredible and like I said what and see
when you start plowing then you're
breaking up that earthworm habitat
you're killing them you're breaking
their channels though a no-till farming
was something that was like I said in
early 70s it became popularized but the
organic farmer never really had a chance
to use it because again I can't use
chemicals to kill off the leads they
fell off cover crops but I think with
this technique we can start to get them
thinking about it and probably be
developing some grants to expand it and
I've already presented this to some
farmers in Hawaii and my understanding
if they went out and got some fabrics
and are going to try it so start to
break out of the you know the the idea
phase and into the reality phase I'm
pretty happy about yeah well you should
be very proud of it and I could see
great applicability of this technique to
down in Micronesia where people just
really started and try to do some of
this more push towards self
sustainability developing vegetable
crops and things like they can support a
tourist industry they can have more
varieties of fresh foods themselves and
none of its huge a lot of it is this
this sort of ant farm small scale right
so you know and you know tractors
equipment fuel takes a lot of effort to
you know to put make a field that's
that's all we D and maybe cover with
grass and make it acceptable for crop
production but I think now we can just
flatten it out to the point where we can
cover it it doesn't blow away after a
while you know plant like I said plants
don't do too good when they're covered
and then once they die off they break
down pretty quick and yeah I'm pretty
excited that it can really be at
something they said it's new that plants
need light to grow but I think the idea
of the fabric and if anybody can develop
on
new super light fabric oh we could have
some real exciting things happen yeah
exactly this this could go anywhere
though because again just you can ship
that fabric out rolls of it that's not
not really the hard hard thing to do
it's not like shipping out a very
complex piece of machinery yeah hey well
this is great Joe I've enjoyed talking
with you here and I've learned learned a
lot of learn learned a lot the first
time you were on and even more this time
I'm pleased to see that you're
continuing this and developing
developing it in new directions it's
great thank you so much for for sharing
with you and I hope all our viewers will
share this with their organic farmer
friends it's always great talking to you
in the audience for likeable science all
right thank you Joe you take care thank
you very much and have a good weekend
yes indeed so that's about it for
another episode of likeable science here
on think tackle I will see you next week
[Music]
you